[Music]
we're in the bathroom for a while
you haven't asked me one question about
myself I mean it's fine I mean I'm not
like interesting or anything I mean
people do pay me to talk but so what do
you do for a living uh
a comedian how are you so funny
childhood do you ever watch yourself on
screen all the time look at me why
wouldn't I what is a date that you
thought was going really well but it
actually wasn't this one why is that uh
you were just in the bathroom for two
and a half hours what are you looking
for in a partner uh good credit what's
your favorite place in the world
um my bad alone got it good got it what
do you like about your job
I had to travel a lot where is your
favorite place to travel to oh my
favorite place to travel I like
Florida what is your favorite food that
you never actually eat why would you
kind of question like uh both my parents
are dead thanks for asking I I this
bread if you weren't a comedian what
would you be a murderer that's kind of
scary
not to a real man what is the most
surprising gift you've ever received
from a fan
um death threats how would you rate this
date one being the worst date you've
ever gone on to him being the best
actually ten this is kind of the best
date I've been on in a while do you
wanna you know for one another date or
like what's your Vibe uh
high five I'm not Jojo siwa I don't know
what my vibe is I'm an adult woman with
a home I don't have a Vibe I have
diagnoses do you want to hear those I
think I'm gonna just leave now well you
know enjoy the bread hope to see you one
day in the future cool
love you
foreign